colombia ha vivido este miércoles 28 de
abril una jornada de paro nacional en
sus principales ciudades los
manifestantes han salido por distintos
motivos pero el principal ha sido la
nueva reforma tributaria que plantea el
gobierno de ban duque y que este
manifestante a continuación nos explica
más en qué consiste
los ciudadanos están marchando porque la
gran mayoría de ellos se sienten
defraudados con el gobierno por la nueva
reforma tributaria que está haciendo
tránsito en el congreso la república
donde se están grabando muchos productos
entre esos dos de la canasta familiar
colombia vive su tercera ola de la
pandemia y está siendo la más crítica de
hecho el país está registrando más de
400 muertes diarias en la última semana
y además las principales ciudades tienen
las ocupación de las unidades de
cuidados intensivos por encima del 90
por ciento sin embargo como nos cuenta
esta manifestante el cod y 19 no ha sido
una excusa para no salir a marchar nos
parece también que que pues es necesario
hacer esto porque ellos siempre hacen lo
que quieren la reforma tributario
básicamente nos va a incrementar a
nosotros los costos de la canasta
familiar cuando inicie
me mostraba ni siquiera tenemos dinero
ya casi para comer yo vivo al día así
que me van echar de la casa porque no
tenía cómo pagar pues adquirí ciudad que
me gusta riendo a pesar de los
constantes llamados para no marchar
miles de colombianos han salido por todo
el país aquí en bogotá por ejemplo ha
habido choques entre manifestantes y
policía
también ha habido llamados de la
alcaldesa de bogotá para que los
colombianos los bogotanos regresen a las
2 de la tarde algo que no se ha
obedecido pero donde parece que ha
habido más intensidad en los
enfrentamientos ha sido en cali a
primera hora de la mañana el grupo
indígena misak ha tumbado una estatua
del conquistador español sebastián
belalcázar y más tarde a la una de la
tarde se ha tenido que decretar un toque
de queda que durará hasta el domingo
hechos que demuestran la grave situación
y el enfado que viven los colombianos